a police officer suggested that
congresswoman Alexandria Cassio Cortes
deserves to be shot and called her a
vile idiot and the term of the day for
the story is stochastic terrorism that's
really the story here and I'm going to
get to that the officer's name is
Charlie Rispoli according to a Louisiana
publication he has been on the Gretna
Louisiana police force since 2005 and he
posted to his Facebook page quote this
vile idiot needs a round and I don't
mean the kind she used to serve of
course referring not to a round of
drinks Alexandria Castillo Cortez used
to be a bartender but rather to a round
as an ammunition he's talking about
bullets
she needs a bullet is what a police
officer is saying the police chief says
it's a disturbing post and if accurate
it does violate the police department
social media policy but and here's the
thing I want to focus on the police
chief says it's not an actual threat
against Alexandria Castillo Cortez from
the police officer presuming I guess
that the police officer means I don't
believe the police officer is likely to
find and shoot Alexandria Acacio Cortez
and that's what I want to talk about we
can talk about all the obvious stuff the
cop should not be on the police force
how do you trust this guy to keep your
neighborhood safe if he has the poor
judgment to suggest on the Internet
under his name under his real name that
not that it's any better to do it
anonymously but I mean it shows sort of
like a lack of judgment as well to think
it's not gonna have no consequences to
suggest publicly that a member of
Congress be shot we would all mostly
agree that even if you don't like a
o'seas politics this guy shouldn't be
suggesting she be shot she shouldn't be
shot and a police officer in particular
saying that is wrong and should be
removed from the police force let's
focus though on this isn't a real threat
okay this is really important this type
of defense might make sense until you
are enlightened about stochastic
terrorism I've talked about this many
times before
I think this even came up on my Joe
Rogan appearance stochastic terrorism is
when someone goes and commits a crime
they commit an act of terror
a shooting a killing whatever they
appear to have acted completely alone
they are apparent lone wolves but in
fact they were influenced by a broader
movement or an ideology that they
weren't personally in contact with at
least not in terms of like a two-way
communication so if I have a TV show
with a big audience and I rant and rave
every day about someone's got to do
something about AOC and some guy that
watches but doesn't know me personally
starts to think it's a good idea to do
something about AOC and then that guy
goes and does something that is a
stochastic terrorist I'm not legally
guilty as the host at least not under
current law but my statement to an
audience when the audience is big enough
becomes statistically more and more
likely to influence someone to actually
go out and do something like this and
right now it is the president who is
doing this so understand the cycle here
Trump rants and raves about the
unamerican bad Congress women who hate
the US they should go back to their
quote original countries people at a
crowd react by literally chanting send
her back about one of those
congresswoman Ilan Omar in that case and
the defense that we heard from the right
is they weren't literally saying deport
her it was more symbolic it was we
disagree with her agenda well it might
be all fun and games except now here's a
cop influenced by this entire anti AI C
apparatus and he goes and posts on
Facebook AOC should be shot the defense
from his own police chief well the
comment wasn't okay violates our policy
but this is not an actual threat that
the police officer is going to find and
shoot alexandria Castillo Cortes
personally but then someone could go and
see all of this stuff and then really go
and do it in real life because that's
exactly how stochastic terrorism works
by fomenting this environment where
these ideas are repeated in more and
more places not only do we hear from the
president we're seeing it even from our
local police I mean look at all these
people that think something should be
done maybe I should be the person to go
and do it
the perpetuators of the rhetoric can
hide behind a microphone
or behind a social media page or behind
the supposedly a symbolic nature of
these statements and say it's AI
pathetical this is not advice to anybody
but statistically you have to understand
stochastic terrorism you are increasing
the chances that someone goes and really
does shoot someone am I saying it should
be illegal to have a show in which you
say something needs to be done about aoc
because somebody who is arguably
potentially unstable goes and does
something no I'm not saying that this is
not me
repressing speech or suggesting speech
be repressed or suppressed in any legal
way what I'm saying is these ideas that
we can just stand surround with coy
language and then say it's all symbolic
it's hypothetical it's just another way
of saying we disagree with her policies
and hiding behind that it's absolutely
ridiculous I saw Dilbert creator Scott
Adams who I've interviewed a great
defender of Trump doing this on Twitter
he said no one is literally suggesting
sending a la Omar back to Somalia this
is symbolism and politics that all the
rhetoric being normalized actually puts
people in danger and it should stop it
needs to stop right away and we need to
call it out clearly for what it is
we'll see what ultimately happens to
this police officer I don't know what
his future holds at least not based on
the sort of mealy-mouthed comment from
his police chief